The world
will remember this day.
The Trinity Test and
the revelation
of the first atomic
explosion to the world
was one of the most important
moments in 20th century.
The Trinity Test and the
development and the race
and the fact
that it was all
attempting to save kind
of humanity from fascism.
What was really interesting
was going back
and trying to understand
what these guys were thinking
and the terrible decisions that
were placed in front of them.
I knew this was going to be
one of the most important things
to technically figure out.
When Chris makes a film,
he wants to do
as much as possible,
practically, and it's absolutely
all about creating a world that
the audience can identify with.
In the start, everybody is
just scared shitless.
Everybody resets sequence.
Nobody knows how to approach it,
because with Chris, it's
always the same.
We have to figure out ways to do
these kind of things in camera.
And every time
when you get sort of
overwhelmed by it,
you take a step back
and you make it a
little bit simpler,
you know. And slowly, you know,
a scene like this sort of,
grows and comes to life.
We try to get permission
to shoot at the actual Trinity
test site at White Sands
Proving Grounds.
Unfortunately, as a proving
ground is busy with bombing
runs and, you know,
all these different things,
we weren't able to physically
fit in their schedule.
I got with the scouts
and I said, okay, well,
this whole stretch
looks the same,
essentially. It's the same
mountain range.
And so we moved 60 miles north.
So we were in the exact
placement, just literally
60 miles up here.
At Trinity there's so much
you can dig into as far
as schematics and
the way that the telephone poles
were laid out and the wiring.
We just followed the research
in terms of dressing
the interior bunker.
The really cool thing
is you could
physically go into the bunker
and go up to the window
and there's your tower and,
you know, we could cheat
the distance in the lens.
It was pretty unreal.
Who builds a 102 foot
replica of the Trinity Tower?
There's so much historical
stuff out there.
You want to make sure
it looks right
and you just do the research.
Building the gadget itself,
that was fun.
We're able to kind of help
tell a little bit of that story
of how it gets assembled,
the core and the
plutonium and all that,
you know, and how
it all goes together.
Chris likes everything
kind of for real,
you know, like the winch
and everything set up for
the bomb was pretty legit
the way it was.
Walking on Ruth’s set,
that's where I really felt
this is what they
would have seen.
This is really what
this looked like.
This is where they detonated
an atomic bomb.
And we think there's a chance
that when we push that button,
we destroy the world.
Chances are near zero.
Near zero.
What do you want
from theory alone?
Zero would be nice.
It's an extraordinary moment
in human history.
And I wanted
to take the audience
into that room
and be there
for that conversation
when that button is pushed.
You're dealing with the biggest
themes, the biggest
of moral dilemmas.
And what's at stake, you know,
what's at stake is insane.
One of the trickiest
things was to kind of plot
Oppenheimer's
sort of moral journey
through all of this,
because he's kind of dancing
between the raindrops
of this kind of moral puzzle
that he was confronted with.
It's happening, isn't it?
Cillian’s performance is
so mercurial and so subtle
that you're kept
guessing as to what
this guy's intentions
really are, because you see him
become the king of the hill
in Los Alamos,
and quite like it.
It was a very conscious thing
for Oppenheimer,
he was very consciously
creating his own iconography.
It wasn't an accident,
the hat and the pipe.
That was very thought through.
I think the silhouette is one
of the most important signatures
that you could create
for a character.
The silhouette is
what takes the audience
through their journey of the
story that's before them.
There are no real color
photos of Robert Oppenheimer.
There is a colorized photo
in Life magazine and from that,
the most important element
was the blue shirt.
And so we decided that
Robert Oppenheimer
will always wear a blue shirt.
Our continuity was really aging.
Some people had four
or five different looks.
I think the challenge is
to, on IMAX, create
all of these known people
and do the journey
of their life on film,
but with that kind of detail.
I think that's
the biggest challenge.
I ended up going to an optician
and got a pair of my glasses
magnified, and then I do
my checks with those glasses,
which have ended up
in a funny way,
being called the IMAX glasses.
Detonator’s charged.
What I knew from experience,
having done, you know,
a nuclear explosion via
computer graphics
in Dark Knight Rises,
which worked
very well for that film,
and I was very pleased
with everybody's
work on that film.
It showed me that with
a real life event like Trinity,
that's as well documented,
the footage is very accessible,
that computer graphics
would never give you
the sense of threat that you
see in the real life footage.
You know right away you're not
doing the explosion
that they did.
So you got to figure out a way
that you're going to at least
get something big,
something we could repeat from
different angles
and was going to kind of
get it right.
[On set chatter]
Because, you know, people
definitely take a better
look at his movies
and especially the accuracy,
on a film like this.
So on this show a lot
the effects work
is, you know, special effects
and visual effects
very much bundled together.
Andrew, together
with Scott Fisher,
their whole sort of unit
was one big science project.
This is a thing
for simulating the shockwave
from the atomic bomb.
There's a slider
to cover this bed
in thin dust
and then release that.
And these as little wires slide
under the dust it
kicks up like a little shockwave
The two of them
did a lot of R&D, they did a lot
of experimentation.
They came up with some
very interesting analog methods.
Two, one, zero.
A lot of different
types of explosions,
a lot of different frame
rates, approaches to how to film
it with the camera, a lot
a lot of different things
going into that sequence.
On top we have
about 60 gallons of gasoline
with some high explosive.
And we detonate that
and then about 2/10
of a second later,
we detonate some aluminum
powder for some bright flash.
And then about almost a half
a second later,
we detonate the mortar
at the bottom, which is gasoline
and diesel and black powder. And
that pushes up through to kind
of create our mushroom cloud.
We're hot. Here we go.
Roll cameras. Rolling,
rolling. Speed!
[On set chatter]
I think for modern day effects,
this is kind of bigger
than normal.
Back in the day,
a lot of this was commonplace
on a lot of movies,
but I think now they-
well, not quite this big.
It's also all about buildup.
Jennifer, she's a brilliant
editor with the help
of like classic film
language and editing.
You know, they build
up this crescendo
that is really, really,
really, really impressive
in so many different ways.
For me, it's like the lead up to
that was the most interesting.
And like, you know these guys,
you've been through it
with them. Learning their faces
and you know who looks like what
and who looks scared, and
who looks super confident.
So you're like rooting for them
and you want them to be safe.
There's a point where
the music takes a big shift
and that's when they're getting
ready to do the final test.
And the whole musical tone
just completely changes.
Going from things
that sound like music to things
that doesn't sound like music.
So I'm using all these
different sound effects
and making that
into a very stressful emotion,
using it as- using music
more like sound design.
You can feel it
more in your body
than in your ears,
and it just feels very uneasy.
It's an interesting
kind of point
where you can almost like breath
out, but with a big tension.
With the Trinity test, I
approached it moment by moment.
I found first hand
descriptions really intriguing
and really inspiring.
It was really just all the
little details, all the little
bits of machinery
they used.
Old analog
equipment humming.
All this equipment is more
or less period accurate.
You know, the solenoid activates
the detonator,
but all these sounds
are just meant to kind of
keep us in the
suspense of waiting.
There are moments
that demand silence.
It's kind of counterintuitive,
because in movies you expect
to hear the explosion.
when you see the explosion.
When it does go kaboom,
you have been lulled
into this sense of astonishment
that is all about playing
contrast to get the reaction
out of the audience.
Our work here will ensure a
peace mankind has never seen.
Until somebody builds
a bigger bomb.
What we were able to do
for the Trinity test
and get into the finished film,
to me is extraordinary,
beautiful
but also very frightening.